tausende gefangene berichte über
polizeigewalt und folter doch die
proteste gehen weiter welche form haben
sie denn mittlerweile angenommen paul
ronzheimer für uns live in weißrussland
ja moritz ich verstehe ganz in der nähe
des postens kaya platz ist das ist der
platz wo am dienstagmorgen ein
demonstrant ums leben gekommen ist und
hier hinter mir siehst du wir vor allem
frauen weiße rosen in den händen tragen
und man sieht die menschen haben hier in
diesem land das so gefragt ist von dem
diktator lukaschenko sie haben die angst
verloren und sie haben vielleicht
erstmals während dieser proteste das
gefühl dass er wirklich gehen könnte und
dieses gefühl haben sie auch aufgrund
der meldung der zwischenzeitlichen
meldungen dass lukaschenko ins ausland
geflüchtet sei
das ist mittlerweile dementiert worden
weiß man etwas über seinen
aufenthaltsort
auch wenn man hier mit den demonstranten
spricht keiner weiß wo lukaschenko ist
es gab einen austritt von ihm aber
niemand weiß so zu sagen ob es am ende
dazu geführt hat dass er geflüchtet ist
oder ob er wirklich hier noch im land
ist er hat sich nicht vor menschen
gezeigt möglicherweise traut er sich
nicht von menschen
man sieht hier im übrigens wie hier
feiernde feiernde menschen an uns
vorbeifahren und jubeln also zum thema
lukaschenko scheint ihm fast ein
bisschen egal zu sein was mit ihm ist
sagt es das nicht nur heute demonstriert
wurde sondern dass vor allem fürs
wochenende am samstag und sonntag große
proteste geplant sind und dass die
menschen wirklich eine riesen hoffnung
haben und wenn man mit ihnen spricht
dann hoffentlich auch das europa dass
deutschland in diesen stunden auf dieses
land schauen